CBS News chief Washington correspondent
major Garrett it's also up there in
frosty Manchester Major good morning it
looks like with sandals and Buddha judge
both at the top of the board again they
can both claim to be frontrunners but
when we look at the numbers of people
who decided in the last minute even that
eenie meenie miney mo voter this race
still looks very fluid major it does the
late Clovis our charge is important but
there are two narratives at the top of
this race and it's the Sanders narrative
hey yes I will was late at a catastrophe
but he still won the popular vote
Sanders supporters would say any wanted
here that's to popular vote victories
that should make Sanders the undisputed
frontrunner the counter narrative is
from mayor Pete boo to judge you said
well that's true but guess who's leading
in delegates the key metric for winning
the nomination its Pete Buddha judge so
those two narratives are competing
leading this ticket and then you have
Amy Klobuchar who continues to defy the
odds and do better than expected and
build momentum which is going to make
the next two contests very fascinating
when Joe Biden focuses on Nevada and
South Carolina and makes the point that
look this is a diverse electorate and
the two states that have voted so far
have not been he's right however is it
too late for him to reset his campaign
no one's gone this far without a big
victory no one has gone this far
finishing 4th and 5th and vastly under
expectations and when you make an
argument that you're the most electable
Democrat in the field and you can't back
that up that's a serious problem and
look at this stage presidential
campaigns when it comes to money are
simple and they are not sentimental when
money begins to dry up your
effectiveness and visibility on the
campaign trail diminishes that's what
Joe Biden faces and he's got to turn
that fundraising and visibility around
in the next five to ten days can he do
that do you think major I know it's all
up for grabs but what are your thoughts
well it's very very difficult for Joe
Biden to collect money right now when he
is so conspicuously underperformed what
do you invest in with a candidate yes
you invest in the candidate but you also
invest in the results and the results
have been very very poor what does Joe
Biden say to his donors hey guess what
fourth and fifth equals ninth which is
what me what do you do with that message
you have to rely on hope and some sort
of expectation that you're going to
vastly turn it around but you have so
conspicuously underperformed and all
those ads in Iowa about the most
electable Democrat they ring hollow now
and that's a serious structural problem
for the Biden campaign all right major
we're just getting started so much can
happen still thank you very much